brandon carter the commissioner federal
trade federal commission communication
commission
warned apple's ceo
tim cook and alphabet ceo
sundar pichai of an alarming new report
that shed fresh light on serious
national security threats posed by tick
tock
tick tock is not what it happened what
it appears to be on the surface it is
not just an app for sharing funny videos
or memes that's the sheep's clothing car
road
at its core tick tock functions as a
sophisticated surveillance tool that
harvests
extensive amounts of personal and
sensitive data
tick-tock available to millions of
americans through apple and google
online stores is owned by the
beijing-based company by dance a
organization an organization that car
asserts is
behold to the communist party of china
required by chinese law to comply with
the prc surveillance demands i i would i
would understand this under a trump
administration to come out a story like
yeah but if it comes out under trump and
biden guess what it is it's real yeah i
agree 100 it's real how do you feel
about this yeah i mean i i don't have a
tic tac i i've thought about it i think
it's appealing like as you know a tool i
thought about it for the show but i am
concerned about this you remember when
trump brought this up and everyone was
like oh that can't be he's just trying
to shut down a company he's trying to be
you know he's he's now big daddy
government but the reality is there's a
lot of stories there was a story that
came out in buzzfeed recently about this
that was talking about how there was
data of u.s users that was accessed by
entities in mainland china so it's a
concern are they harvesting data what
are they doing with the data if are they
holding on to it what kind of personal
data are they able to retain
what are they going to do with it i mean
you don't want the chinese government
having access to that data so it's a
concern i'm so you know and it's
interesting to me because this has been
a story that's now gone through two
administrations this doesn't seem like
it has a political bent to me it doesn't
seem like it's a part of a political
narrative so i'm surprised that more
people aren't tuned into it and this is
tick tock is the home of young people
right young people are plugged in left
and right so do they not care like does
that is this not a concern at all i mean
privacy privacy i understand people feel
like in 2020 too you know privacy is
dead but they're talking about your
personal data your personal information
that could be the posses in the
possession of the chinese government so
yes absolutely 100 this is something
that crosses my mind every single time i
consider doing a tick tock i take a
pause i sit back and i don't do it
because i'm worried about where this
data is going who's holding on to it and
then they said something about oh we can
modify this and we can have you know it
be controlled within the united states
well that doesn't matter it doesn't
matter all that data is still going to
be transferred over to china it's still
going to be in their possession so i
think it comes down to a question these
are again this doesn't seem to be
politically motivated this is crossing
two administrations are you comfortable
with your personal data potentially
being in the hands of mainland china and
the chinese government if no you might
want to consider your presence on tick
tock if yes i don't know what to say and
i'll pick you back on the floor and i
think this is what's messed up today you
could tell all these all these kids all
these you know middle-aged people that
are on there
the truth and what's happening they're
addicted they're not they don't give a
sh you could tell them they're making a
[ __ ] ton of money even though they wanna
interrupt you they're making a [ __ ] ton
of money yep 100 you can tell them to
their face this is all going to china
that you know
it's oh you god knows what the hell
they're doing with it you know they
would say okay fine whatever i got i
gotta leave i have to go make another
video same thing with that remember that
old face swap app yeah
look at all the everybody and their
mother was doing it was during the
pandemic that's a russian-based company
that the facial recognition facial
recognition they got all your goddamn
faces
and that that comes back to my point i
was i was actually talking about this to
rob earlier bro china is they're they're
just gangstable they can do whatever
they want they own us they can get away
with everything but still to this day
like we still haven't held them
accountable for covent isn't that crazy
that's how gangster uh china is what are
they gonna do with it though the data
you're thinking about like think about
an influencer you know a 20-something
influencer now making half a million
dollars a year off of tick-tock videos
because they do you can make a [ __ ] ton
of money and it's not hard to make money
on tick-tock because of the way the
algorithm works if you post a lot you
can make a lot of cash which is why i
was like should i consider that it's
good show promotion but what is the
chinese government that's the other
thing because i think people sit back
and they read a story like this and they
say well what are they gonna do with my
stuff i'm just an influencer i'm
promoting products i'm 20 something
years old they're not going to harm me
what what so what that's the question
for me too though well you know how is
it like what are they going to do your
picture your images your personal
information
your voice what what is that data breach
what is the potential where can that
land that can be scary for your average
25 year old who sees themselves as
disconnected from this story i don't
know yeah well they say you know uh
regarding social media if you're not
paying anything for it and you're not
buying a product you are the product 100
okay so with tick tock i believe this is
china's sort of tick tock trojan horse
into america and trump has been talking
about taking away tick tocks for two
years now right yeah but
for young people two things
they've grown up with scroll scrolls
girl except they don't they're not
reading the disclaimer what's happening
with the data so what they're doing
three things to take away from young
people they're taking away their minds
right needlessly just scrolling seeing
stuff that's not helping their lives
number two they're taking their time and
like you said number three they're
taking their data what they're going to
do with their data whatever the hell
they want to do who knows with the data
why do you think tesla
is
almost at a trillion dollar market cap
or when it was it's not because they're
selling the most cars ever it's because
they're collecting data they're
collecting data tesla i think elon musk
is famous he said we're not a car
company we're a data company yeah so i
remember that so let me say a couple
things here so i i i eventually ended up
on tick tock okay and if you follow my
tick tock content
it's what tick-tock doesn't want for it
to be on okay so that's my approach with
tick-tock
and the audience is young so if i'm in
the job of persuading you to consider
other options and philosophies in life
i want to talk to people that are
disagreeing with me i don't want to talk
to people that agree with my talk to
people that agree with me who am i
converting nobody i want to challenge
your way of thinking that if you
disagree with me i've been putting
content on tick tock for about a year
now okay
and a few of them go viral one got five
million views a few of them like 10 of
them got a million views and they they
spread by the way much faster than
instagram it's not even insanely yes two
videos
one of them got me taken off of tiktok
for a day that i send an email to them
and uh support and they apologize
the video that got taken down is when we
talked about nancy pelosi's husband
uh uh making the stock the people that
were saying if you want to be able to
predict the market for invest in
whatever nancy pelosi's husband invest
in
i got i got taken off of tick tock for
that surprise i sent an email to them
and they tic toc support on tick tock
got back and said i'm sorry it's a
mistake of ours you know what's the
other one that's been taken that's not
been taken down that they
took down the video but they didn't uh
uh suspend the account it was when we
talked about aoc's biggest nightmare is
who
aoc's biggest nightmare is who do you
see remember when we say here look at
this
community guidelines
violation right this video what's the
thumbnail just read the thumbnail
aoc's worst night aoc is worse now do
you remember who we said aoc's worst
nightmare was who did she go with on
twitter
oh when she was going with elon elon
musk that video is to say aoc's worst
number because and when when elon said
hey i'm shy don't do this remember that
whole thing crush on me they have not
this video was uploaded may 27th this
video has not been taken uh back and i
disputed it and they said we've had your
dispute we're still considering it it's
been over a month so it's stuff like
this that tick tock does which tells you
politically which way they're leaning
why did you not take those videos what's
the big deal i didn't say we didn't talk
about vaccine it was not mask it wasn't
covet related yeah it was a nothing
about that aoc and pelosi both of those
reasons the videos got so now brandon
card this guy brandon carr who is
brandon carr he's so here's who brandon
carter check this out the guy got
nominated
he was he ended up being chosen to be
the federal communications uh uh
commissions
in 2017 guess who assigned him that job
a guy named donald trump
he he was he was confirmed august of
2017. do you know what's unique about
this when you get this job guess how
long your job is how long is your term
five years oh wow guess when it's five
years is coming up next month
so he may be getting fired i would not
be surprised if this guy gets fired
within six weeks
if he gets fired within six weeks this
is his last chance to bring attention to
tick tock being a concern and we're
going to see if they're going to do
anything about it
if this guy does get fired just assume
it's to protect tick tock if the current
administration biden
chooses to investigate this and go a
little bit deeper that means it is a
topic that they're both on the same page
with and by the way before speculating
let's see if brandon gets fired six
weeks from now if he gets fired six
weeks from now we can speculate as of
right now all i'm telling you is the
guy's job expires in the end of july
okay so let's follow the story to see
what happens to this brandon car guy and
there's a and there's a reason that his
term i'm assuming is five years it's
because you're not gonna get fired when
the administration comes in you're gonna
at
navigate the waters and transition but
are you not concerned because i remember
you were debating we've talked about the
tick tock you weren't on tick tock over
a year ago i don't know china trump but
you must have said all right
there's the pros and the cons kind of
like the the angel and the devil you
must say all right the pros i'm gonna
you know put out content i'm gonna
convert you know the the convertible
speak to people different but you must
have some data concerns no i of course i
have some data concerns but my concern
is more philosophy concern so you know
people say why would you bring uh so
many communists that you're interviewing
do you not realize they're
indoctrinating young people who watch
your content
no
i want to talk to those guys so there
are arguments you get to choose and say
well that definitely didn't make sense
like remember the guy that said i'm
going to give 70 000 salary to all my
employees do you guys remember that one
story yeah what was the price
right if you've never seen this
interview go watch it i told them i said
i can't believe you accepted the
interview with me
uh because uh but i'm impressed that you
did so i said so how did you structure
your company he says i don't believe i
see he says i also only make seventy
thousand dollars a year so really yeah
everybody in my company only takes
seventy thousand dollars a year i said
wow it's very interesting
but i applaud you i said what's your
company do we do around 40 million
dollars in numbers per year okay so if
we take 20 of margins 30 on margin so
it's about a 100 million dollar company
he says yes he's got a school you have
to watch i said yes i said so the same i
said so how many employees do you have
he said 100 employees i said so i'm
assuming you've also given a percent of
the company to all your 100 employees
because that's when it means you're a
total socialist where you're being fair
with everybody who owns the entire
company i do
well i said dan if you really are so
concerned about your employees
when do you plan on giving each of them
a percent
if you've never seen this interview i
gotta go you have to see this interview
he says i think he should go full
so so go one more step
you know don't just stop at 70. take a
percent and give it to everybody
well you know technically tax i can't
say no you can't do that i've done that
i did that myself i gave some shares to
my guys not 100 of them but i also don't
agree with you the fact that everybody
should make 70 grand i think some people
should make more money and some people
should make less money and so we should
get fired to subsidy so we get
promotions
so the point is you go on tick tock
where the young people are to say huh oh
that does kind of make sense but i can't
agree with it that does kind of make
sense but but i can't agree with it
that that does kind of make sense i
gotta agree with it
[ __ ] i agree with too much stuff this
guy's saying damn this is not good yeah
because my professor i loved
he would have hated this guy and what
he's saying
but i'm starting to like what they're
saying yeah what is going on to me am i
like getting that's why i'm on tick tock
mm-hmm my god does that make sense yeah
i'm working money on tick tock like
what's my am i trying to go do a
video on tick tock to be famous no
that's not the strategy the strategies
to get these guys to be looking at let's
see so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]